budget isn't the variable of success
being consumer Centric is our industry
is getting really far away from that the
Barbie execution one on different
relevance points like we're not trading
on relevance enough please give a war
welcome as he makes his way to the stage
it's Gary
[Applause]
V Gary I would welcome you to Australia
but you know this territory very well
don't you
yeah first of all thank you so much uh
it's really really really nice to be
with everybody uh yeah I grew up in the
wine business um I launched an
e-commerce wine uh site for my father's
liquor store business in
1997 and so I was a very early advocate
of the expansion of Australian and New
Zealand Wines in the late '90s and early
2000s so I've been here many many many
times and have spent tons of time in
Valley and Margaret River and Barosa and
other places and so um it's it's really
one of my favorite places in the world
and it's really nice to be here so we
have a room here of there's a there's
just over a billion dollars worth of
budget in this room it's [__] it's
actually insane I'm interested
so so I this is going to be a discussion
if you guys want it to be so stick your
hand up there's people with mics around
they'll give you they'll give you a mic
and then I'll I'll I'll throw to you
when I'm when I'm ready but
you are the best in the world I think by
a long way at being able to see around
corners in the marketing space so to the
billion dollars in the room what is
around the corner you know it's
interesting I I don't think that I
actually see around corners I think
our you
agree uh I think that this in you know
it's I grew up
Marketing in a manner that was very
focused on driving sales because because
I don't know if any of you have a Soviet
immigrant father that owns a business
but my father wasn't super interested in
Awards he was interested in what was
happening at the cast register I also
knew that my dad was only 22 years older
than me and this whole concept he told
me which is like when I die you get the
business I also know he has pretty good
genetics I was like Dad you're going to
be 90 I'm going to be 70 I'm going to
have to I'm going to have to do
something for myself one day so you know
the first 15 20 years of marketing
career I was trying to drive day-to-day
sales but I was trying to build a brand
because I knew there' be a day I would
leave and I wanted to leave it in the
best place that it could be and so when
I got into the Fortune 500 marketing
World 14 years ago one of the more
interesting observations I had pretty
quickly and definitely the answer to
this question is I don't think I really
see around corners I think our industry
is incredibly good at putting yesterday
on a pedest
and putting tomorrow on a pedestal and
struggling to maximize today and for me
you know things like making real
commitment to social media creative and
media isn't around the corner when I get
credit for being right about Tik Tok it
had hundreds of millions of users that's
not seeing around the corner that's
understanding that this was hitting
scale but the companies in the world
weren't doing it because it wasn't
measured yet and if it's not measured
it's not being done even if the
consumer's attention is there and in
that Delta is where I tend to play um
that being said I spend enormous time
paying attention to things like AI or
the metaverse and things of that nature
I just don't like spending actual
execution dollars on it because I don't
think the consumer attention's there
versus the value so you know I
appreciate that I I do feel like I've
done well in first mover advantage and
things that nature but one of the things
I'm most proud of is I don't have too
many things that I've been horribly
wrong about and it's not because I'm
smart it's because I only talk about
things that already
happened so I think you're telling half
the truth because you [__] say around
corners I can name a number of examples
but can we get some hands please who's
got a question so we can get a mic to
okay we'll go there but I I'm going to
ask you one question before we we get
that
one you have Vaya medeor is such an
incredible agency I don't know if you
call it an agency but it's all over the
world and you work with the most
incredible Brands doing the most
incredible things so you have exposure
to CMOS all over the world what is
different or what do you notice that's
different about Australian CMOS to the
rest of the
world you know nothing that I think is
so profound I think CMOS continue to to
be challenged by the same things my my
biggest hope and dream for all the CMOS
Australia and every other part of the
world it you know starting to have the
real conversation of putting them in a
position to succeed where if if we can
get the CMOS around the world to start
pressuring agencies to bring back media
and creative Under One Roof well then we
can actually hold the agencies
accountable to actually driving our
business which then will make us much
more popular with our CEOs and board
members you know my career because of
all the things I did before and in
parallel to what I'm doing with the
advertising agency I tend to spend a lot
of time with the CEOs and the board
members of The Fortune 500 companies and
their
frustration is the reporting that is
happening within their own companies and
I keep yelling at them I'm like you're
the CEO it's your fault but you know I I
do think
Australia more than other parts of the
world skews a little bit more academic
when it comes to marketing I think
there's more conversation of the
Academia of it uh that stands out but I
mean this is what a very Dynamic Market
we you know we wanted to ENT enter this
Market because for us we we like
underpriced media and there's a lot of
arbitrages in this country because I do
think that there's still too big of an
allocation to traditional media and so
there's a lot of opportunity within
influencer or bitable social I think
when you think about what's going with
on with streaming and 7 plus and things
of that nature I think TV is going to
change very rapidly here in everybody's
faces over the next 5 to 10 years and so
I I think the opportunities High I think
the creativity is very strong but I
think the creativity is only interesting
if it's actually
consumed what do you mean I mean that
the our industry globally not just here
um is very infatuated with grps and cpms
that aren't actually being seen by human
beings okay there we go question hi Gary
uh my name is Jack for context we've
just had advertising week uh in
Australia which obviously brings all the
great marketing Minds together uh a lot
of the conversation was around AI data
yes um but what I found really
interesting was Ai and please correct me
and tell me if this is true or not that
it currently responds to uh white male
as if it in terms of the results and how
it
speaks how do we as a society and also
AI uh grow and adapt to make sure that
we're aligning with the humanity and
also the social conversation and
progress that we see rather than AI just
speaking to a white I don't think it's I
don't think it's speaking to a white
male the the conversation that is
fascinating about this is people are
talking about you know the inputs and
how the you know the data is being
structured you know I keep trying to
remind people like everything has
Prejudice there's nothing in the world
that doesn't I think the cool thing is
is that the blockchain and AI are are
open opportunities for people to create
the data sets and so it's not catering
to white males it's that a lot of white
males have been working on the
technology right so you know I think
this stems to much bigger
infrastructural things this talks about
education this talks about a million
different variables that Society has
been struggling with since the dawn of
society um you know I to
me people are like oh we need to make
sure this AI is not spitting out things
that aren't balanced I'm like all of the
content that the world is consuming is
not
balanced there's nothing that's balanced
it's the nature of the flaw of the human
I think what's more interesting is when
are human beings going to finally start
falling in love with
accountability instead of us spending
all of our time being mad at media and
social media influencers and algorithms
maybe it's time to start having
conversations about Humanity's capacity
to take in multiple data sets and
actually make decisions for themselves
maybe the bigger issue is that we like
blaming things that are exposing Our
Truth so I'm going to we've got a
question there we we Gus we've got a
question there um before we get to that
I'm going to keep picking on AI
okay if I'm a marketer right now
yes what the [__] do I do with AI
probably not much like you you should be
educated you shouldn't say no there's
not a person in this room given what
they do for a living and where they are
in their careers that shouldn't be
playing with AI probably on a weekly
basis given how massive of a technology
it's going to be that's just going to
affect your life forget about your
professional career not playing with AI
today would be like the people you made
fun of 25 years ago not going on the
internet you know like it's really funny
watching people deal with AI or the
blockchain they like people
are so in love with no they hate change
so much that most people don't realize
they've become their
parents right the thing you made fun of
your parents for of like not knowing how
to use email or or not wanting to go
away from the Blackberry to the iPhone
or all the things that you've spent the
last 30 years making fun of you've now
become you know and so I would encourage
people to play with it because your
personal subjective opinion of
technology has no impact on technology
and what it's going to do and so I think
that people should be playing with it
but there's a lot to go with AI for
example all of us if you're paying a
little bit of attention are aware that
generative creative is going to be a
very big deal the reason for a lot of
people in this room we can't go there
yet is we all know that the copyright
and trademark issues are looming and big
companies can't be posting that creative
yet because there's liability but that
doesn't mean you can't start doing it
maybe for some internal use to build
decks and play with so I would just say
like this is a training wheels phase
right and really you should be doing
this for yourself because there is no
outcome where this technology is not
profoundly important and I think that is
the bigger issue um and
opportunity hi sir hello um I loved your
com what's your name cam cam um I love
from where introduce yourself I'm from
opice I run consumer marketing opice I
used to work with Mel she left me it's
very sad um uh uh everybody that Mel's
ever left has been pretty sad yeah yeah
it's it's yeah it's um it's rough I
loved your comment about bringing media
and creative back together how how do
you think about finding creative talent
that wants to work in that type of
environment and how do you Foster a
creative culture that needs to be
responsive to results and not the
cigarette smoking I'm an artist creative
that from yesterday that is a very smart
question no question the biggest
challenge so Vayner media started 14
years ago I owned a I owned I I ran a
wine retail business for my father um
and then I started the agency I knew
nothing I've never heard of anything
that I now know of in this industry I
didn't even know that media and creative
was separate I and in 14 years we built
a company that has 2,000 employees and
is a very large agency globally and by
far the biggest challenge in those 14
years is to give creatives more
self-esteem it is stunning how
insecure the creative directors of ad
agencies are around the world and the
lack of humility and curiosity is
devastating and the retraining of all
the creatives that we hire from the most
iconic shops um is extremely challenging
they'd much rather believe that their
subjective opinion in a boardroom is
right than black and white Quant and
qual data and so you know we do it with
empathy with a lot of training with a
lot of you know for us what's working is
three years ago we made a pretty
substantial decision which was every
single creative globally would make
creative every day so our entire
creative Department globally actually
makes creative every day and as we all
know cuz we're in the industry most
creative shops are not in the business
of making actual creative they're in the
business of
making decks and pitching ideas and then
you then get a company to make the
production as we've been able to get
these creatives to start making it's
been really fasing that has been the
Breakthrough for us to answer your
question because they are now living in
a more merit-based world they're
starting to get more excited about it
some I mean many quit you know people
people really want to so we've done more
Super Bowl spots in America in the last
four years than any creative agency
which is like a brain twist for
everybody cuz we're so positioned as
social but as it's happening now PE and
we have a very good culture like
actually no [__] so we're we're
we're rolling now we get the inbound
from widen and Crispen and droga Senior
creative people and they all talk that
[__] to me when I interview them they're
like I'm [__] ready I'm done with
this [__] industry it's all [__]
I'm coming and when they come in their
first creative meeting when somebody
who's 23 years old has a different
opinion and they talk up they're stunned
they're like what the [__] are you doing
talking and I remind them like no no you
just told me you were ready for
this they're not ready for this it's
much more fun when they just get to
pontificate their you know great ideas
can come from anywhere they like to say
but they don't live that life and so
it's a real challenge it's it's one of
the biggest Investments we make it's
enormous amounts of training
predominantly it is therapy
and um and we actually make that you
know we really actually train that way
we put in a ton of time in The Upfront
hiring we like really try to tell people
were like listen you're not going to
like this your opinion does not matter
more you make and then six you have no
idea how to make social media creative
so we're going to train you but like are
you really ready for this level of Merit
and the answer is almost none of them
are so tell me the difference then
between creating good creative on
outdoor and TV and bad creative on
outdoor and TV versus good creative on
social or bad creative on social so what
what is the difference when you execute
either way on either side you can't hide
in
Social you post and real stuff
happens and when you post something bad
on
socials it goes nowhere right if you
post something put something bad on a
billboard We Make Pretend it did
well because you know 6,000 cars drove
by it and 3.7 people are in every
[__]
car so then okay it's it's a what you're
what you're talking about is this new
world where you're accountable for your
creative that is very terrifying for
every CMO because it's like how do I
hire for that how do I build for that
that that is a lot of [__] work I
actually think this is what CMOS
subconsciously want to lean into I think
it's way more scary with the tenure ship
of CMOS around the world I actually
think leaning into accountability and
measurement would actually free us up
like we as an agency beg and plead for
our clients to give us media and
creative and hold us accountable to the
business results at the end of the year
that's how I built my whole company
anytime we don't we're vulnerable
we're always vulnerable you
know we've got a question in the corner
yes sir Twitter Twitter Rebrand
yes
comments I think the Twitter rebrands
interesting I I think for all of us like
intuitively it's like [__] that's giving
up a lot of brand right but I understand
the logic of why doing it because a lot
of people have in here have had the
experience of trying to Rebrand or
create new products and features under a
brand and for a lot of consumers they
already know you as something and it's
really hard to convince them you're
going to do these six other things so I
think look I think there's some you know
he I think he has a lot of emotion for
x.com that he bought a long time ago was
probably looking for a use for it I
think that comes along with being that
kind of entrepreneur but the logic is
that they're going to try to build a
full stack
multi-dimensional new app and I think
the strategy there is if we start with a
fresh slate there's more acceptance of
it being able to do that and look at the
end of the day that story is going to be
written based on the execution right
naming is funny because at the end of
the day names are executed if Google was
a shitty company and didn't do well you
could that name sucks but because it
wasn't it doesn't suck right McDonald's
is a local pub in Ireland or a global
qsr giant the execution made the name
there so I think to me I think what
happens in the next 5 years on execution
will then tell the story about the
Rebrand but that's a lot of brand Equity
to give
up we heard from Nick at twilio at the
start talk about a cookist world what is
life going to be like and what do we
need to be thinking about post iOS 14
iOS
15 well first of all most big brands in
the world don't live in that world
anyway there's no cookies on
TV there's no cookies on outdoor there's
no cookies on direct mail or print or
event
marketing so you know I think in a
digital landscape it forces Brands to
realize that the creative variable right
now is a very big uh conversation a post
iOS 145 World also collided at the same
time with the tiktock ification of every
social network so for the first time in
the history of marketing the creative
barrier iable creates
reach think about how fascinating that
is for all of us for the first time ever
the actual quality of the creative
working on consumers creates the
reach that is a profoundly important
conversation it also leads to how the
best companies right now currently are
attacking the iOS 145 issue the best DTC
Brands and performance brands are
winning on a very aggressive organic
social strategy that extracts when
creative over indexes or goes viral and
then they convert that creative into
performance ads because the intent and
interest in that creative has been
affirmed by the reality of it doing well
with the actual consumer the the fact
that we could use modern social
creatively to mitigate our risk on both
performance and campaign work is a
golden Goose but the disrespect for
social media creative by the overall
Global Marketing industry is not letting
us take advantage of
it hey hey you back yeah I'm I'm back
sorry I that's okay um you're just not
passing the mic yeah no that's take it
if they want it yeah um so right now all
the big management consultancy fir
management consultancy firms all BCG
McKenzie or rolling around with a AI
here's how you change the structure of
your marketing team here's what you do
and it's going to save you all this
money you can fire a bunch of people and
isn't that amazing yes um what and you
know here's how you optimize all your
social creative and D what and it it
feels like the advertising industry
marketing industry is like a step behind
on this what what is your response to
the CEO that says why shouldn't I do
this like why shouldn't I take those 15
people and turn that into one person who
knows how to prompt this and let
machines run all this like what like the
see around the corner thing like what's
the what's what's going to slow the role
or or where's this thing going with
management consulty I think it's
frustrating because most of the
companies here are run by their CFOs
against a stock price every 90 days
that's the least creative thing on Earth
you know and so we're we've that's the
reality of what big business looks like
in today's world um and a lot of those
CEOs used to work at McKenzie and so
it's all in the family and so you know
what's my answer to that it's going to
be something in between I think people
that don't bring value always get put
out of business by
technology and so it'll be an in between
I mean I think for a long time you're
still going to need the creative but if
you were in the business of just
executing somebody else's idea in Adobe
like you're going to be hurt if you're
the person coming up with the idea you
you're going to be able to stick around
a little bit longer so I think you know
I think there's going to be validity to
it I think a lot of people are always
looking for excuses to cut costs AKA
people and some of them will run with it
and other people will realize that
that's not the place to cut cost so I
think you're going to see a mix in
between got a question
here you're oh sorry sorry sorry sorry
I'm going to be controversial and
Suzanne I think we all can agree that
the Barbie campaign has been extremely
successful yes but Gary yes if you were
to execute the Barbie campaign as it was
today what is one more thing that you
would have done to make it even more
successful I mean you know you're
literally talking about a campaign that
I called
Richard you know the the former CEO he's
obviously going to Gap now to be the COO
and said this was just so well done you
know I mean I I haven't looked at it
enough like there's nothing in the world
of marketing that didn't have an
opportunity to do something else but
that the 360 nature of that campaign was
so well done in the mix of the vigital
world of like the digital stuff they did
the I think the thing that I took away
from it was we've been pretty bullish
back home on experiential as a platform
to produce more creative so when we
think about event marketing we think
event marketing if you really are
filming all of it is an incredible you
know studio for production and if you do
it very efficiently There's an
opportunity to basically have one of the
two things basically be free either the
event has a cost and the creative out of
it became the added value or you could
even look at it the other way creative
is way too overpriced in advertising so
you know
in a world where there's so many
campaigns that FR frustrate me to no end
and I think there's so much opportunity
it's really hard to get my juices going
at a campaign that is so clearly so well
thought out and executed and you know I
to me what probably if I if I really had
to do it and I had five hours to look at
it it would probably come in the science
around the creative structure of the
social creative the thing that we are
really deep on
is the thumbnails the time you post the
science around the art and social is a
humongous variable and something that I
don't think the industry is doing enough
of yet and and I think there's always
opportunity to maximize that including
most of the things we put out into the
world thank you Mel hi I'm Mel he Mel I
used to work with
Cam there you go were you sad when you
left him uh I don't know I I'll be
completely honest this is completely off
piece but I
interview yeah I don't
know um I I want to ask you a question
that's less about marketing and more
about leadership so as an
entrepreneur you're actually incredibly
rare in the fact that you really believe
in karma and paying it forward and the
time you give to individuals and the
belief that it will pay off why because
it always pays off because you don't
need anything on the other side doing
nice things is the
payoff it's just how I see Humanity you
know I don't I don't do nice things with
like and then I'm going to get the deal
I think that's
manipulation I think doing nice things
because it's the right thing to do is
the win and so you know because I why
because I have a remarkable all-time
worldclass Hall of Fame
mother that's why actually and so um I
just am incredibly fortunate like I
really really won the mom
game that's the actual answer and she's
here right
now Gary this whole um threads launching
when kind of Twitter was you know
fumbling the football a little bit um
was all is Twitter dead you know should
I do threads should I do this should I
that what where should I go your answer
on Twitter was pretty profound or X was
pretty profound you had the most
important word in marketing and I want
you to share that with us
and and and is the most important word
in marketing we are infatuated with or
in this business as if we don't have
enough money to do
everything right we just I just don't
understand why we would say which one of
these two should you they they both have
attention one of my wildest Things that
I'm fascinated by is when a cpg business
tries to portfolio manage they're like
all right we have these seven Brands and
this beer is going to be for women 18
into and this one and I'm like why
wouldn't you want to sell all of them to
everyone so we do all these things in
the boardroom that has nothing to do
with the consumer you know to me I you
know I I just think that we should be
doing a lot more I know why we we really
do have an issue creative is too
expensive in our industry
if you have any you know um time spent
outside of our world in in Silicon
Valley and small businesses and and
influencers and director like just it's
crazy how little we put out creatively
for the costs we put into
it and but once you get over that hump
everything is
anned why wouldn't
you there's a small group of
high-profile
people in the music industry here how do
you think about marketing an artist when
you're just trying to get the streams up
and cost per click is going to be way
too much for a for for the stream that
you would get how do you Market a brand
how would you break a brand new artist
if you if they're under your agency by
only signing artists who prove they know
how to
Market that's what I would do we have a
whole you have to understand every
artist that's coming up the game
now what's that we're going to get you
to repeat that oh I'm sorry you know to
me we now live in a world if you think
about artists I think we can all you
know not every artist there's plenty of
artists in their 30s 40s 50s breaking
but I think we can all agree that in the
music industry quite a few of the
artists that are being signed are coming
up and they're in a certain age group
where most of these artists now are
equally creators right and you know this
the anr business has changed quite a bit
like you don't need to go to the bars at
2: in the morning and find them you just
go to the social platforms and see it to
me it's very clear to me and I spend a
lot of time looking at emerging
artists it's very clear which artists
understand how to be
creatives and I think for me to answer
your question I I wouldn't take the risk
of signing an artist just on the quality
of the music there's too many people
with Quality Music and some of them also
know how to create creative for the
platform that have the end consumers
attention and then once you have that
the artist is doing the work you can
build infrastructure around them but
they're native to the understanding of
how to create right I mean Lil Lil nzx
is a growth
hacker more like he's a growth hacker
like he was at going at that for a while
and then he figured it out Lil nox is
more Mr Beast than he is Kanye West and
that is a blueprint to where this is
going and so you know but if I was
because if you're trying to break an
artist the problem is and we know this
like what Logan Paul and KSI are doing
with you know Prime and what Mr Beast is
doing with beastes like the human now
has the leverage most of the competitors
in a meaningful way of the consumer
brands in here are going to be human
beings going
forward cuz the humans have such scale
of audience and such
understanding this is why the creative
question was such a great question we're
a long ways away from commercials that
people give a [__] about it's been a
long
time that's
sh you go I'd like to unpack that a
little bit
so my name is Liz from too segment great
to have you here thank you um so I want
to talk about Mad Men versus math men so
I think it was IBM that wrote that more
data has been produced in the last two
years than the existence of mankind
that's right and with the move away from
growth at all cost to profitability and
streamlining um can there be a world
where creative like creativity lives can
coexist alongside datadriven advertising
and data driven marketing which comes
first and you know they have to dance
together but it's really interesting
your question is it can it and my answer
is it does everywhere but our
industry like every o like all the
things that our companies buy the
marketing that they're doing is the
balance between math and art like that
when you're a startup or when you're a
small business that's all you look at
you know the balance and the other part
of the equation that we've
systematically eliminated from this
industry is common sense my biggest
frustration is when I look in a room
like this with the sheer t talent that
the companies have stripped you away
from making the common sense decision
we're just reverse engineering the
report that justifies the
behavior a good mmm which is just
grading your own homework because if the
numbers don't come in right you know it
rained on Tuesday so we have to
adjust so does the data feat the
creativity or is it the creativity that
informs the data both when you're an
actual practitioner of this it works
both ways you you make decisions and you
make creative that's been informed by
data but then you're also doing a ton of
creative things that you are able to
then postgame and learn and affirm from
it you're doing both but like big data
everyone's got big data okay now what
what are you doing with it there's not a
company in here that doesn't have
unlimited [__] big data
congrats you got a you got big data you
got a great data Lake you like your data
Lake like we're just we're we've gotten
very very far away from the
consumer question we've gotten very far
away from the
consumer F first question on this side
of the room hey Gary my name's Chris I'm
I run cinemano group with like content
creation agency it's a pleasure just
want to backtrack to your previous
answer please um we're talking about in
the music scene trying to find way for
artists to Break um on the opposite end
of the corporate side we're seeing a lot
of like you said Logan Paul KSI we're
seeing a lot of micro and um
non-traditional creators overcoming um
the barrier where traditional content is
not succeeding so you're finding a lot
of these like big Brands who were
struggling to land on Tik Tok but then
their same product is hitting with a
16-year-old in the US and all of a
sudden her Tik tok's going viral do you
ever feel that there's going to be a
return where traditional and big scale
companies will overtake and micro and
like young creators won't have that same
power anymore of course not the cost of
Entry is equal corporations are slow and
expensive of course not they can't win
it's a merit
game of course it worked when it was TV
normal human beings couldn't buy
television you I didn't wake up at 17
I'm like I'm going to buy some TV
today no the the no it's going to get
worse like way
worse but do you feel like the
accessibility so for example a really
big thing on Tik Tok at the moment is um
that talking head type of content so
Alex hzi is done it really well the big
blown up subtitles everyone sort of got
access to that now on a lower level with
an iPhone and the captions app um do you
feel that the accessibility that's now
widespread do you feel like there's ever
going to be that time where like now
budget puts you ahead or is it an even
playing field through through now no
because I mean you're only talking about
a creative framework that's working this
second things are moving too
fast budget isn't the variable of
success being consumer Centric is I I
you know our industry is getting really
far away from that you know the Barbie
execution want on different relevance
points like we're not trading on
relevance enough this industry runs on a
book that was written in
it is it's just you know like the the
basic principles of frequency and reach
dictate the way big companies Market the
concept and the book came out in 1991
the internet didn't exist I mean it did
but you know what I mean right so no I
don't think our production money is
going to help us win the game of Merit
when we're becoming less consumer
Centric not
more we literally think that our brand
positioning should be a vanilla
statement that means something to
everyone by Nature it means that it
means nothing to No One Like every
single brand positioning that everyone
trades on in our industry is like just
some [__] Manan four words to Toyota's
brand positioning is let's go
places like what do we do with
that like they're still going to make a
video with a [__] car going up a
mountain
like we're really we're just not having
real conversations and when you don't
have real conversations for a long
period of time bad [__]
happens but I can tell you one thing in
the last 20 years is the biggest brands
in the world have lost market share
because of the reality of the internet
holding companies have made a lot of
money why because they separated media
and creative and now they don't have to
be held accountable
it's really hard to be a service
provider when you're beholden to your
shareholders the bigger question is why
do why do why does this industry spend
most of its money on TV and programmatic
because I can tell you those are the two
most profit centers for agencies and I
find that
curious couldn't agree more we've got
one last question lucky last hi Gary we
met this morning yes um so it's
interesting though you said that um
you're making more Super Bowl ads than
any other company how are you affecting
change cuz I see Super Bowl ads as
probably the most expensive over
produced creative probably ever so
what's the change there our thesis is
not that television's bad or social's
good our thesis is that we should buy
the best attention for the best price we
can we believe that Super Bowl is the
single best deal in marketing in the
world that for $8 million we get 170
million million Americans actually
wanting to watch our 30 seconds to your
point that's just the media buy the
media buy is the best on actualized
consumption actual reach not potential
reach to your point the issue is most
agencies use that 30 Seconds To Be A
showcase for their agency not to drive
the actual business result and most
brands want to spend on a celebrity
which ends up building the brand of the
celebrity not the brand so I think
there's a lot left to do proper
advertising within a spot but we view
Super Bowl as the most underpriced media
globally like we look at everything I
mean Out World Cup patches there there's
some hacks there but to get 170 million
people to want to watch your 30C people
don't want to watch your social media
videos either it's just that it's so
well integrated into the product and if
you're good at making them people will
watch
them right if if if social media feeds
had the same natural break that
television had nobody would watch them
either we're prepped to not watch We're
condition to not watch Super Bowl is the
reverse the entire country of America is
excited for the whole week to actually
watch the advertising so that's a
profound opportunity so we see that a
little bit
different are you allowed one more
question
please sing wait wait just wait cuz we
need to get you recorded can we get a
mic here you
go video avod streaming advertising what
do you
think so I think that um the targeting
capabilities of the future of television
and streaming abod fast channels all of
it is really profound it is much more
aen to the Google Facebook ecosystem and
it's really exciting my concern is that
the unit itself is still going to be so
hard stop disruptive you know to me I
think where TV has a real opportunity
since they control the distribution is
to actually start integrating product
into shows even if they don't own the
production company since they own the
distribution they might be able to start
partnering directly with the production
companies so my intuition tells me it's
not going to be as great as it could be
because it's going to be again too
disruptive um but I haven't seen it I
can tell you that the Roku ad product
targeting wise is is
incredible um but look I think I think
for a lot of people here they're
underinvestigated yeah the data the data
of like targeting is it that in itself
makes the product 10 times better I'm
I'm very excited about that but the
creative is look creative is still the
variable of
success like the ad is the punchline um
my big thing is that we we just got so
accustomed to assuming it was actually
seen and we do so many things to cover
up the stuff that's not working we're
really sales organizations there's
Shopper marketing there's retail media
there's in scoring systems that are
adjustable if it didn't work out there's
just a lot of weird [__] going on and um
I like Merit more than weird
[__] Gary I think I speak for everyone
the billion dollars in this room where
I'm going to say a huge thank you so
everyone give Gary a real Round of
Applause thank
[Music]
you
yeah